ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. MYSELF. YEAH.
SUBCOMMITTEE. HERE. AND WE'D
LIKE. WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE, SENATOR. AND MR. ALBIANI.
AND YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT SB
551. THAT'S RIGHT. ALL RIGHT.
AND WHAT? SHOULD I PROCEED? AND
WE'D BE WILLING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM FOR US. YEAH. YEAH. LET'S
DO IT. REPUBLICAN FRIEND, PLEASE
ESTABLISH THE QUORUM. SENATORS.
ALLEN. HERE. SENATORS. DALI
SENATOR NGUYEN. SENATOR SKINNER.
HERE. SENATOR. GONZALEZ AND.
SENATOR HURTADO. OKAY. THANK
YOU. SO WE HAVE A QUORUM.
APPRECIATE IT. THE CHAIR. YEAH.
WE HAVE A QUORUM, AND YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
SB 551 WOULD CLARIFY APPROVE
REPORTING PRACTICES ACROSS
PLASTIC BEVERAGE MANUFACTURING
COMPANY PRODUCT LINES.
REGULATION OF PLASTIC
MANUFACTURERS HAS BEEN A COMPLEX
ISSUE. IN 2016, AB 2530 PASSED
WHICH REQUIRED MANUFACTURERS TO
REPORT INFORMATION ABOUT THE
AMOUNTS OF VIRGIN PLASTIC AND
POST-CONSUMER RECYCLED PLASTIC
IN THEIR BOTTLES SOLD DURING THE
PREVIOUS CALENDAR YEAR. THE
LATTER PASSAGE OF 793IN 2020
WERE CREATED. MORE ISSUES, AND
SO SB 551 WOULD ADDRESS SOME OF
THE, SOME OF THE ISSUES
AUTHORIZING SPECIAL BEVERAGE
MANUFACTURERS TO COMPLY WITH
POST-CONSUMER RECYCLING CONTENT.
IT'S A CLEANUP. AND NECESSARY,
TIME SENSITIVE BILL. AND WITH ME,
I HAVE DENNIS ALBIANI, WHO WILL
SAY A FEW WORDS. MISTER ALBIANI,
YOU MAY PROCEED. I'LL KEEP IT TO
A FEW DENNIS ALBIANI ON BEHALF
OF AMERICAN BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION
AND CONSUMER BRANDS ASSOCIATION,
BOTH IN SUPPORT, THIS BILL
CLEANS UP A PROVISION THAT WAS
IN 793 BY TING AND IRWIN FROM A
FEW YEARS AGO, ABOUT REPORTING
HOW MUCH, RECYCLED CONTENT YOU
HAVE IN YOUR, BOTTLES. AND SO
ALL IT DOES IS ALLOW REPORTING
ACROSS THE ENTIRE COMPANY'S
PORTFOLIO. NOT EVERY SINGLE
BOTTLING PLANT, WHICH IS HOW,
CALRECYCLE HAS INTERPRETED THE
CURRENT BILL. AND SO THIS WAS
ACTUALLY DISCUSSED WHILE 793 WAS
GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS, JUST
NEVER GOT REFERENCED PROPERLY.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE CLEANING
UP WITH THIS BILL. APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND GLAD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. GREAT, ANY WITNESSES?
IN ADDITION, ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
COME TO THE MIC TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. COME ON
UP. YEAH CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
BRUCE MAGNANI, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF PLASTICS
RECYCLERS AND THE RECYCLING
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. GREAT, ANY OTHER
FURTHER WITNESSES? ANYONE?
OPPOSITION RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS?
MOVE BY SENATOR DALI. OTHER
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. WE'LL LET
YOU CLOSE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY. LET'S CALL THE CALL.
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN SENATORS ALLEN. AYE AYE.
DALLY. DALLY? AYE. GONZALEZ.
HURTADO. MENGIBAR NGUYEN.
NGUYEN. AYE. SKINNER I. SKINNER.
AYE. OKAY. THAT HAS THE VOTES.
SO WE MAY WE MAY JUST GAVEL DOWN
BECAUSE I DON'T, GIVEN THE
EVERYONE RUNNING AROUND. YEAH IS
THERE SOMETHING ON THIS DRESS?
NO. THANK YOU. ANY SORT OF
SECOND FOR YOU GUYS ON THIS?
PORTANTINO. YES. LET'S GO TO THE
SERGEANT FIRST. YEAH HE SET UP A
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LET'S WAIT A FEW
MINUTES AND THEN.
I GUESS.
YEAH. YOU'RE ON YOUR WAY.
THE FIRST TIME YOU BEAT US HERE.
HAHA. YEAH. ALL RIGHT.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE PORTANTINO BILL. OKAY,
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0 WITH
THE CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR.
VIÆT. AYE. VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HURTADO. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE. OKAY CAN WE GO
DOWN TWO PEOPLE? LINA IS IN A
MEETING.
ALL RIGHT. I'M GOING TO ADJOURN
THE HEARING. WE HAVE THE VOTES.
THE VOTES? IT'S WILL REPORT IT
OUT 5 TO 0. IT'S ON ITS WAY.
DON'T WORRY, CHRIS.